with my students a lot of them have not  had a lot of academic success they've  faced a lot of obstacles  that's what great about khan academy is  they have success and so i think that  really builds them up they're all  working on the same  program but they're working on very  different things and the great thing  about that is there's no judgment  they actually love  khan academy so much that they  approached me to start a club  that was specifically doing khan academy  they're asking to do math work  outside of the regular school day like  totally their own motivation these kids  are creating social connections and  boosting their self-esteem and just  feeling great about themselves all  through the connection of doing khan  academy